This is Jason.
He has more than
2,500 band shirts,
enjoys 80s thrash metal albums,
has a dog named Bela Lugosi,
drinks black coffee
in the morning.
And I sue government
agencies for information.
I'm Jason Leopold
and I'm an
investigative journalist.
Money laundering, corruption,
covert programs.
Secret Service
visiting celebrities.
I have the luxury of
dipping my toe into any subject.
I've been described as a
FOIA terrorist by the FBI.
I've also been referred to as
a member of a FOIA posse
by the Department of Justice.
And the NSA has actually said
I've weaponized the FOIA.
The Freedom of Information Act,
which is commonly known as
the FOIA, is a law
that gives you the right
to access information
from the federal government.
It's a half-century-old law.
Often described as a law
that keeps citizens in the know
about what their
government is doing.
It's an incredibly powerful tool.
So I first got involved with the
Freedom of Information Act,
probably about 15 years ago.
And really where
it started to pick up
was during Occupy Wall Street.
I started to file requests with
the FBI related to their role
in allegedly dismantling
the encampments
that were set up
around the country.
Remarkably, the FBI responds
to my FOIA request
by stating they had no records
and they could not
locate any records.
So, I had hooked up
with an attorney.
And he told me, well,
we can sue the agency.
We can sue the FBI.
And I was like, wait what?
I can sue the government?
Uh, where do I sign up?
And wouldn't you
know, once I sued them,
they found those records
that they said they could not find.
And from that moment on,
I just kind of kept filing requests
and suing the government.
I'm constantly
filing FOIA requests.
I've easily filed more than 5,000.
There are instances
where I'll be driving
and I'll hear something
on the radio and I need to
pull over because I have
to get the request filed.
Really, what I'm trying to do
is to pry loose records so
I can build out investigations,
but also trying to get records
that would enlighten the public
and shed light on
hot-button issues.
I think the FOIA is underutilized
by the general public.
Journalists only make up
a sliver of requests that are filed
on the federal level.
There's certainly been an
uptick in the use of FOIA
over the past
decade or so.
But the majority
of the FOIA requests that
federal government agencies
receive are from
commercial requesters,
people who are taking that
information and selling it.
They're not requesting records
that are in the public interest.
They're not sharing those
records with the public.
The FOIA request is what
I refer to as a template.
My template says,
this is a request
under the Freedom
of Information Act.
And I cite the law and
I'm telling the agency
exactly what I'm looking for.
So it's a very simple process,
but it can also be painstaking.
And here's why.
Agencies are not so eager
to turn over records.
And I just sit back and wait.
But sometimes waiting
can take years.
It's like Christmas
when I get these.
Whoa, whoa.
US Treasury, Financial Crimes
Enforcement Network.
And this is a request
that I actually filed back in 2017.
So, it's taken the
agency about six years.
There really is no
general wait time.
There's more than 400
federal government agencies.
So depending on the agency,
the requests can take anywhere
from three months to ten years.
The least amount of time
that I've waited for documents
was about two days.
I would say that the record
of documents that arrived
on my doorstep
in one day was probably
about 7,000 pages
from the State Department.
And I think that they did
that as a **** you to me,
knowing that I'd have to thumb
through each and every page.
The request that had
the most impact
and I mean the most impact
was for Hillary Clinton's emails.
We are all accountable to
the American people to get
the facts right.
And it was my request
and my lawsuit that became
the vehicle by which
all of Hillary Clinton's
emails were released.
And by the way like,
I had no idea she
had a private server.
I was just trying to get
the public to be like,
Hey! Look, it’s her emails.
Anyway.
The FBI has uncovered new
evidence in its investigation
of Democratic presidential
nominee Hillary Clinton's
use of a private email server.
Donald Trump is praising
the FBI's decision
to review new emails.
Another FOIA request that I
filed and ultimately a lawsuit
that resulted in
thousands of records
that were released
that had enormous
impact were records around
Robert Mueller's report into
whether or not Trump
had colluded with Russia
during the campaign of 2016.
I was able to get
Donald Trump Jr's name
unredacted from
the Mueller Report.
I've gotten records
from the government
where they talked ****
about me in emails.
And one time,
the FBI sent an agent out
to investigate one
of my FOIA requests
and I only found out about that
because I filed a FOIA
request with the FBI.
The most rewarding part of this
job has always been holding
power to account and
speaking truth to power.
That is really what
keeps me going.
And being able to shine
a light into dark places.